voilà qu'à mairie
mais qui a tué pamela rose avez vous un
regard du moins il ya les arrestations
avec les voitures de police l'américaine
avec les giraud qui tourne ya des scènes
de morgue évidemment comme dans tous les
temps tous les grands films américains
il ya des scènes cultes 1 par exemple
qu'on vous avez la main dans la main de
johnson vote soit 5 heures jendoubi ait
joué par greg germain
et vous arrêtez pas le mec est dans le
coma il n'arrive pas à tirer va
maintenant passer une journée avec la
main et aussi cette histoire quand vous
êtes dans un bar avec une fille vous lui
faites une vanne ça passe pas du tout du
tout et j'ai fait le service après vente
d'un livre les simples et banales et
s'il vous plaît le mec corrige laval
séquence économique ont des problèmes
mais vas-y l'appel ce service là et bien
là mais ce n'est pas toujours une
solution c'est quoi un numéro tu
l'appelles souvent toi il ya un mec qui
demande un autographe au shérif marley
interpréter donc par jean paul rouve et
puis si notre avis pourquoi vous
demander de graphismes si j'adore les
robes que moi j'adore ce genre d'humour
sur ce qui est marrant c'est qu'on a
quand on a vu le film la première fois
on s'est dit c'est exactement le film
qu'on voulait faire c'est vraiment ce
que ce que ce qu'on fait depuis dix ans
sur grand écran
espèce de tout est remontée d'un coup et
on a eu l'occasion de le faire le show
cinéma ça donne envie d'aller le voir
sauter montée d'un coup et je suis bon
souvenir ému je sais que c'est un film
très chiadé parce qu'elle est que
lartigou de faire un film comme dit
chabal est refait le film très chic mais
tu sais que lartigau crise qui l'a fait
partir où il a fait la pub pour les
bouloches 1 christine bravo monsieur
format qu'avait directs savaient pas
c'est énorme
ouais c'était non donc c'est pour ça que
dans le suivant des pulls et on est tous
en train de se laver
c'est bien en tous les cas c'est un vrai
film américain